we all want to be in optimal shape what
does that actually feel like what are we
really aiming for here this of course is
going to vary from one person to the
next we will have ideas of what's
desirable maybe your ideal physique is
that of a bodybuilder or maybe it's a
gymnast maybe you just want to be free
from pain sometimes though what might
surprise you is that the person with
your ideal physique could be struggling
with similar problems
Optimal Performance doesn't necessarily
mean optimal fitness and health so to
return to the question Optimum fitness
and health doesn't feel like anything
your body falls silent because it just
works it does the thing you wanted to do
in the moment without restriction you
don't feel insanely buzzed but you're
not too tired to summon strength or
enthusiasm there are no aches and pains
and whether you want to hike up a
mountain play sports with a friend lift
heavy Furniture focus on a long essay or
play with your kids your body Rises to
the occasion optimal Fitness then feels
like freedom
[Music]
bye for now